donald trump uh did not go to joe
biden's inauguration
breaking with tradition the first
president
in i believe 152 years not to go to
their replacements inauguration trump
left he went to
florida early this morning but on his
way out
he did leave the white house and take
the marine one helicopter to andrews air
force base and before getting on air
force one for that final flight
delivered a five or seven minute speech
and
said even more things that make no sense
to a very deflated crowd
trump asking to be remembered if things
improve under biden
trump saying if things do get better in
the next few months it's because of me
please remember me you're going to see
incredible numbers start coming in
if everything is sort of left alone be
careful
very complex be careful but you're going
to see some
incredible things happening and
remember us when you see these things
happening if you would
remember us because uh i'm looking
at uh i'm looking at elements of our
economy that are set to be
a rocket ship up it's a rocket ship up
very powerful elements
of the economy that he's looking at as
he says there
how long overdue is it for this
nightmare to be over
this morning's speech really reminded me
of that trump's still using the term
china virus another aspect of how this
morning's speech was
almost the same as the campaign speeches
trump had been giving
china virus it's a horrible thing that
was
put onto the world we all know where it
came
from but it's a horrible horrible thing
so be very careful
be very very careful but we want to pay
great love great love to all of the
people that have suffered including
families who have suffered so gravely
uh and then i mean listen that's really
the first time i've heard trump sincere
sort of sincerely mention the people who
have actually
suffered from the virus trump for good
measure
he can't get away from these things
again claiming the 1918 flu
started in 1917 we don't know why he's
been saying this for a year but he said
it again
put it in a position like it's never
been before despite the worst plague to
hit since i guess you'd say
1917 over a hundred years ago
and it is a goodbye for now as donald
trump
pledges to be back and says have a nice
life to the crowd sort of the send-off
we would expect from the guy who never
really cared about his supporters as
people
he cared for about them only in so far
as it was useful to his political goals
the things that we've done have been
just incredible
and i couldn't have done them done it
without you so just
a goodbye we love you
we will be back in some form
and again uh i wanted just in
living i want to thank our vice
president mike pence and karen
i want to thank congress because we
really worked well with congress
at least certain elements of congress
but we really did we've gotten so much
done that nobody thought would be
possible but i do want to thank congress
and i want to thank all of the great
people of washington dc all of the
people that we
worked with to put this miracle together
so
have a good life we will see you soon
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
[Music]
so there it is have a nice life and you
hear ymca
cranking up there a surreal and bizarre
moment and with that
donald trump is done flying off
into the sunrise not into the sunset it
was early this morning flying off to
mar-a-lago in palm beach florida
before joe biden's inauguration alluding
to
we don't know if it's a 2024 run
although i don't expect that
we don't know if it's alluding to there
were rumors of trump starting a new
party to be different than the
republican party
rumors of many different things we just
don't know
but hours before leaving office donald
trump
issuing 143 pardons and i do want to
talk about that
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better
and look better the carefully designed
shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout